I defy any musician out there to tell me
when the muse of music is going to come
visit I don't think in any of us know
and songs come from the strangest places
here's a very ordinary one I'll tell you
about I've never done this song without
playing the piano but I didn't bring my
piano with me in this New York traffic
it was a little hmm yes um Joni Mitchell
and I had been to breakfast at a
delicatessen in Los Angeles I'm walking
back to her car we pass an antique store
and Joni looks in the window and she
sees this beautiful vars that she wants
to buy it was a cold dreary Los Angeles
morning and we get back to John's house
in Laurel Canyon and I say hey why don't
I light a fire and you put some flowers
in that var that you just bought well
Joni went out to get flowers that meant
she wasn't at her piano which meant that
I was which meant that our house was
born about an hour and a half later I
like the fire
you place the flowers in the VARs that
you bought today staring at the fire for
hours and hours while I listen to you
play your love songs all night long for
me only for me
come to me now and rest your head for
just five minutes everything is done
such a cozy rules are chuckles if the
windows are illuminated by the evening
sunshine through them fiery gems for you
only for you
our house is a very very very fine house
with two cats in the yard life used to
be so hard now everything is easy cuz of
you
nah nah
la la la
my mind
my man land
and them
house is a very very very fine house
with two cats in the yard life used to
be so hard now everything is easy cuz of
you
I like the fire while you place the
flower was in the vise that you bought
today
our house on guitar Wow
that's never happened before